it's true i'm gonna let you in on the
end game
of the sjw agenda
or at least the lgbtq plus agenda
or at least the representation aspect of
the lgbtq plus
well at least my version of the okay i'm
dropping this bit
yeah so i think
i this is not really something i think
i've ever been
asked directly or if i have it's been
like
sporadically like maybe it's come up in
a live stream
but i have found myself thinking lately
that as
representation of well
of lots of things but for my purposes
lgbtq plus
people in various forms of media
becomes more common i started to find
myself thinking
well what's the end goal
of that and i don't mean the societal
the societal
end goal is linked to it and is not
completely detached but i'm talking
about
how do we know when
we're done when we've accomplished what
at least i would like to see
accomplished what are the signifiers how
do we know
when that happens and it's actually
really really simple
as soon as a character being lgbtq plus
is no longer remarkable
mission accomplished you know i've said
before i think this was actually in an
interview i gave
that my dream scenario would be to live
in a world in which
a massive mainstream
entity like disney dreamworks
warner brothers what have you could put
lgbtq plus characters in
their all ages mainstream properties the
kinds that
are the backbone of temple films and
make a billion dollars at the box office
when
box office is a thing again and it's
not a headline
the day that illumination
has a non-binary lead in a film
and if a news outlet tries to make a
story out of it the general response is
so what why is that news
ultimately as much as people accuse
folks like me either by nature of our
very existence
or by wanting
better or more representation of people
like us
in media we as much as we
are accused of wanting to be
special uh honestly
it'd be really nice to not be
noticed for something that is simply a
fact of our existence
i need to keep talking about it and
bringing it up until that's the case if
it ever is
but no honestly the goal is to simply
go about my day my life
my opinions and not have this come up
you know maybe the occasional hey nice
lipstick thank you
um but not have it be the way that i'm
defined because
right now it is including in a lot of
ways how i define myself
because i have to because it's something
that is going to be
pointed out and notice first and
foremost about me by
a lot of people so i kind of have to
head the train off at the station there
because the thing is when we get to a
point where you can have
a gay lesbian transgender non-binary
gender queer gender fluid
whatever character
in a show that is intended for everybody
not some niche product a special gay
thing for the gays
and that fact of who they are
is not the defining aspect of their part
in the story
that is going to mean a lot
because the thing is for the most part
not always and in fact i'll even cite a
favorite example where it's
not the case but by and large
we're still at a point where even as
representation becomes more common
whatever the thing about that person is
especially if it's being trans or
things related to your gender identity a
little bit less so these days
with being lesbian or being gay
but for a lot of us this
aspect of ourselves defines what
we get to see done
we almost never get to see a trans
character just
be in a story they're always there
as part of a trans narrative and that's
not to say that trans
narratives don't have value they
absolutely do
but i'm saying you know
i would really like to see a trans
character
where no part of their arc over the
course of the story has to do with their
transition or the fact that they are
trans or having been rejected for being
trans
or the difficulties of dating while
trans or anything related to that
i want an action movie where
some member of a kick-ass all-star hit
squad
is trans and just is
never comes up never impacts the story
and here's the thing this
kind of comes into this whole thing
where so often
people feel that we need to be justified
if we're going to be there which i've
talked about before in that video
but just to reiterate briefly it is so
frequent
for anyone who deviates from the
template of straight
white heterosexual cisgendered
and able-bodied if you deviate from any
and definitely if you deviate from all
five there has to be a reason you can't
just be there
something about the story must
necessitate you being there otherwise
what are you doing here
i know joss whedon has become a bit of a
difficult figure to talk about in some
ways but i'm still going to pull this
quote from him because it
is a great answer now granted he was
talking about female characters as
opposed to this but the principle's the
same he got asked in an interview
why do you write so many strong female
characters and his answer was
i write them because you have to keep
asking that question
that's the thing as long as
mainstream and a significant number of
people are saying but why
are they there then clearly there isn't
enough representation
we need to show up often enough
frequently enough
in enough things in enough numbers not
tokenly but meaningfully that eventually
people stop asking why we're there
and eventually maybe it can get to the
point we're saying
why is why is there a non-binary
character in this story would be like
asking
why is there a left-handed person in
this story
you wouldn't ask that that's a
ridiculous question why wouldn't there
be a left-handed person what
that that's the goal
that's what we want we don't
want to be treated special we actually
want to be treated like everybody else
and also at times ignored like everybody
else
but a lot of us can't be
and often by choice in terms of our
presentation
but look what i do in terms of sitting
down in front of a camera
for a living yes
i do this for attention and it's what
pays my bills
but the fact that i identify this way
the fact that i grew my hair out like
this the fact that i
dye it the fact that i have these frames
they're not for attention they're so i
can feel
more like myself
and even if i'm not doing something for
attention
because if i sit down in front of a
camera yes i kind of want attention
but if i'm going to the grocery store my
p.o box
just to pick up my kid from school
i don't want attention
but i tend to get it anyway because i'm
not just considered
part of the scenery part of the
furniture
still seen as an outsider whose presence
has to be justified
so when you have when when the question
why are you there is no longer asked
then we'll have accomplished something
and if you want to get a glimpse of what
entertainment
looks like where we just appear
and the fact of our queerness
is not made a story point
watch shiron the princesses of power and
if you've seen it before watch it again
because for all of the queer characters
there are in that
nobody is ever surprised
caught off guard or questions
any time we see a same-sex couple
or character expresses love for someone
of the same gender
or beau appears to crush on seahawk
nobody in universe questions that
and it's beautiful and wonderful it's
like they said
let's imagine that we're already in the
world
where nobody needs this justified or
explained to them and it's just there
and it's wonderful it's also very
telling that
it really at this point can only happen
in fantasy stories taking place in
worlds that are not
this one in the world we actually live
in it gets
brought up and talked to death a heck of
a lot
so we are starting to see what this
entertainment can be
what it can look like
so when it can be something that isn't
set
on another planet in another dimension
but it can just appear in anything
without issue without being news
without being questioned it's just
there thank you very much for
listening as with last week there is no
sponsor but
the kickstarter for birth of a joker is
still running i'm gonna put the link in
the description full disclosure i am
personal friends
with uh the person who is running this
thing and i have already pledged
but honest to god check
out the pitch video it is this really
intriguing concept
for a female black anti-hero joker
the pitch is great i want to see this
so bad i've done what i can to try and
help this come about look at the pitch
consider pledging towards it
this is going to be awesome if we can
get there
there's some days left in the
kickstarter i hope you'll check it out
and consider contributing
so thank you very much again i hope you
are
taking care of yourself as we get into
the holiday season
be well be safe be kind
whatever thoughts you have on anything
that i've said
drop them on down in the comments and
let's talk about it
usual stuff you know what it is like
share subscribe there's the patreon
that is in fact how i earn my living and
how i am able to keep doing this
and also eat
even if you're not able to contribute to
that
it's okay i can't tell you what to do
end of the day you're the council i just
run the meetings
and until next time this council is
[Music]
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you